here's what happened the other day
somebody's got money in their 401K
pretty well known persons like hey Pat
man I haven't looked at my 401k for a
while can you just take a look at it
like this is a person that's made real
money I'm like when's the last time you
looked at it not in a long time I'm like
seriously yeah and they're not young how
old are they they're late 50s early 60s
yeah they should be paying close
attention to it but but it's not that
they should be you know it's the same
story with most people should get annual
physicals done most people should get
their teeth checked out most people what
most of us should do and what we do are
two different things most boomers are
not sitting there reallocating their
401ks on time most people reallocated
too late and they're gonna hit the you
know they're gonna they're gonna pay the
price for it so even though you're right
yeah for a guy like you're like dude I'm
not retiring for another 25 years you
know maybe you'll return three years
because your style is different but for
the average person in their late 30s
early 40s yeah it's gonna go for a while
you know people in their mid 50s late
50s early 60s they're not sitting there
reallocating the retirement they're
being hit by